for that update let's take you to
another hot spot in the world the
uk prime minister is speaking now
mr speaker in the parliament british
parliament let's listen to what he has
to say
[Applause]
and i want to say
to the people of this country
i know
what the issue is
yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted
yes we can be trusted to deliver we said
that we would get brexit done mr speaker
and we did
and we're setting up free ports around
the whole united kingdom i've been to
one of them today which is creating tens
of thousands of new jobs mr speaker we
said we would get this country through
covid and we did we delivered the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe and
the fastest booster program of any major
economy
so that we've been able to restore
people's freedoms faster than any
comparable economy
and at the same time we've been cutting
crime by 14 percent building for
40 new hospitals and rolling out gigabit
broadband mr speaker and delivering all
the promises of our 2019 agenda so that
we have the fastest economic growth of
the g7 we have
shown that we have done things that
people thought were impossible mr
speaker and
and that we can deliver for the british
people mr speaker
i just i remind the the bench is
opposite
the reason we're coming out of covid so
fast is at least partly because we
doubled the speed of the booster rollout
and i can tell the house
and this country
that we are going to bring the same
energy and commitment to getting on with
the job to delivering for the british
people and to our mission to unite and
level up across this country mr speaker
and i commend this statement to the
house
i don't call kirsten the leader of the
opposition
uh thank you mr speaker i'd like to
thank sue gray for the diligence and
professionalism with which she's carried
out her work
it's no fault of hers that she's only
been able to produce an update today
not the full report
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know
that 12 cases have reached the threshold
for criminal investigation
which i remind the house
means that there is evidence of serious
and flagrant breaches of lockdown
including including the party on the
20th of may 2020 which we know the prime
minister attended
and the party on the 13th of november
2020 in the prime minister's flat
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
the prime minister must keep his promise
to publish sue grey's report in full
when it is available
but it is already clear that the report
discloses the most damning conclusion
possible
over the last two years the british
public have been asked to make the most
heart-wrenching sacrifices
a collective trauma
endured by all
enjoyed by none
funerals have been missed
dying relatives unvisited
every family has been marked by what
we've been through
and revelations about the promised
behavior have forced us all to rethink
and relive those darkest moments
many have been overcome by rage
by grief
and even guilt
guilt
that because they stuck to the law they
did not see their parents one last time
guilt that because they didn't bend the
rules
their children went months without
seeing friends
guilt that because they did as they were
asked they didn't go and visit lonely
relatives
but people shouldn't feel guilty
they should feel pride
in themselves and their country because
by abiding by those rules
they've saved the lives of people they
will probably never meet
they have shown the deep public spirit
and the love and respect for others that
has always characterized this nation at
its
our
best
story about covert is one of the people
that stood up when they were tested
but that will be forever tainted by the
behavior of this conservative prime
minister by routinely breaking the rules
he set the prime minister took us all
for fools he held people sacrificing
contempt he showed himself unfit for
office
he's desperate denials since he was
exposed have only made matters worse
rather than come clean every step of the
way he's insulted the public's
intelligence
and now he's finally fallen back on his
usual excuse
it's everybody's fault but his
they go
he stays
even now he is hiding behind a police
investigation into criminality into his
home and his office
mr speaker he gleefully treats what
should be a mark of shame as a welcome
shield
but prime minister the british public
aren't fools they never believed a word
of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
[Music]
of course he won't
because he is a man without shame
and just as he has done throughout his
life he's damaged everyone and
everything around him along the way
his colleagues have spent weeks
defending the indefensible
touring the tv studios parroting his
absurd denials degrading themselves and
their offices
fraying the bond of trust between the
government oh
the members so thribbled is my neighbor
i expect better from my neighbours
clearstar
fraying the bond of trust between the
government and the public eroding our
democracy and the rule of law
margaret thatcher once said the first
duty of government is to uphold the law
if it tries to bob and weave and duck
around that duty when it's inconvenient
then so will the govern
mr speaker
to govern this country is an honor not a
birthright
it is an act of service to the british
people not the keys to a court to parade
to your friends
it requires honesty
integrity a moral authority
i can't tell you how many times people
have said to me that this prime
minister's lack of integrity is somehow
priced in
that his behavior and character don't
matter
i have never accepted that
and i never will accept that
whatever your politics whichever party
you vote for honesty and decency matters
our great democracy depends on it
and cherishing and nurturing british
democracy is what it means to be
patriotic
there are members opposite who know that
and they know the prime minister is
incapable of it
the question they must now ask
themselves is what are they going to do
about it
[Music]
they can heap their reputations the
reputation of their party the reputation
of this country on the bonfire that is
his leadership
or they can spare the country from a
prime minister totally unworthy of his
responsibilities
it is their duty to do so
they know better than anyone how
unsuitable he is for high office
many of them knew in their hearts that
we would inevitably come to this one day
and they know that as night follows day
continuing his leadership will mean
further misconduct cover-up and deceit
it is only they that can end this fast
the eyes of the country are upon them
they will be judged by the decisions
they take now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes we can be trusted the plea there by
boris johnson prime minister of the uk
addressing a sentiment prevailing in the
country it's been called partygate the
accusation that he violated
government lockdown rules during
lockdown periods of covid
we heard that sentiment being rejected
by the leader of the opposition ks
kstama saying the prime minister took us
all for fools
let's bring in paul brennan he's at
westminster in london
given what's happening now paul i think
it's safe to say
there's no sign of an easy exit for
boris johnson at this point
and no desire from boris johnson to head
for the eggs yet either i mean uh what
we're hearing there from kiyostama the
leader of the opposition is an
impassioned plea for boris johnson's own
mps to turn on their leader the question
is whether those mps are prepared to
listen to what the opposition leader has
to say and and and do what he wants them
to do which is to send letters of no
confidence
to the 1922 committee and thereby spark
a leadership challenge to boris johnson
it's looking very unlikely that there's
any appetite for that anymore what we've
had
in the last week and a half
since sue gray's report was initially
due to be released is an aventing of
anger and frustration and exasperation
and then the kind of the news cycle has
moved on and
we were waiting for sue grey's report to
come out we then had the metropolitan
police intervene and say that because
they were investigating in a criminal
sense some of the gatherings that
sugray's report would not be able to
have all every cough and splutter of
what went on in this building behind me
during those 20 months it's kind of
taken the power out of the report it's
taken the punch away from the opposition
parties and as a result sue gray's
12-page document eight pages of report
four pages of annexes um appendix is
sorry uh uh really it talks in general
about the culture within downing street
without actually naming names or looking
at any specific incidents or specific
gatherings it certainly doesn't
say that the prime minister personally
was responsible in any way and that's
why boris johnson was able to stand up
and say look you know i'm sorry um i i
can see there needs to be significant
learning but i am going to restructure
the way that downing street uh is run uh
i get it and i will fix it he said and
the question is whether he will that
that would be enough for his mps he's
actually going to be
addressing his conservative mps uh in
the house later on this afternoon so i
think he knows that there's still a
challenge that he needs to overcome uh
to keep them on side um but i think the
prospect of an immediate leadership
challenge
has significantly receded in recent days
all right thanks so much paul brennan
outside number 10 downing street there
let's take you back